I suggest we switch to the first
presenter Chris went or Microsoft Thank
You yep so I I'm going to present about
the Microsoft translator hub which is a
feature of a general Microsoft
translator of service and API first let
me give you a general view of Microsoft
translator here Microsoft inflater is a
statistical machine translation system
you can use it if you visit Bing Bing
Translator as part of the Bing family of
services it's also integrated in a
number of Microsoft products for
instance office or Internet Explorer
when you when you request translation on
these products you will you will get a
translation by our by our system it is
big data powered it's trained on
billions of parallel sentences the
training data is acquired to a large
part from the web but we also license a
lot of additional data that is used as a
training corpus to build a system it is
it provides a general-purpose system
doing a decent job on on average content
you can translate between more than 40
languages any of any language of these
two any other of those and it comes with
an unprecedented customization
capability we have two features that are
targeting customization to a specific
domain or application space that is the
hub which we are going to talk a little
more deeper today that is training the
system for
so far unknown content future translated
content and the collaborative
translation framework which is a
real-time customization where you can
receive feedback from your users your
community your employees your
translation service provider which has
an immediate effect on on your system
and your life your life side I can do
another webinar about about that feature
but today we're going to talk about hub
which is really training your own empty
system it's provided by a powerful cloud
API we provide a number of integration
integration points it's hosted in the
big data center with high availability
and distributed around this is an
overview of the couple of the primary
integration point on the left side you
see a number of Microsoft products that
allow you to consume Microsoft
translator and a on the right side a
selection of the of the partners and
we'll hear from landbridge later on
today here is some detail about the
features we offer soap rest HX and OData
interfaces to the to the translation I
should say that rest and Ajax other are
the most popular most developers are
consuming the service why that interface
but if you were for instance a
sharepoint customer you can use it as a
sharepoint native feature and and employ
all the the sharepoint scripting and
integration functionality there we offer
a webpage widget which you can
it's the easiest and simplest way to
deploy automatic translation on your
website it is a piece of JavaScript you
can include on your site and it gives
your visitors the ability to to request
translations in their language or you
can configure it to be automatically
translated in their language and it
gives you direct access to the
collaborative translation framework as
well as a customized system without any
coding overhead other than pasting the
piece of JavaScript in the into your web
page the full functionality of the
widget is available through the API so
if you do not like the APA the the the
visual appearance of the widget you can
you can fairly easily we implement that
within your own with your own UX
paradigm for customization and that's
what we're going to talk about more
today the hub is a a portal that allows
you to build train and deploy customized
automatic translation system which will
then be optionally combined with the
with the generic microsoft translator
bacon giving you the best of both worlds
and hosted the same way as as our
general-purpose API in distributed data
centers around the world giving you with
the same scalability throughput and
reliability as the as their generic
machine translation has been
traditionally used in two different ways
post edit in to speed up the human
translator we see in practice a
productivity increase between 0 and 25
percent that is in market softs own
observations taking taking into account
all the the overhead and management that
is associated with that in the video
translators report much
better productivity increases as
measured at the translator and
themselves another way is raw publishing
where you publish the the output of the
machine translation engine directly
without any human human review works
West best with a bilingual user
interface allowing user access to the
original as well as the translation and
we see very good results with technical
audiences I'm promoting a a third way
here call it a p3 or post publish post
editing that really makes use of the
community of domain experts enthusiasts
employees professional translators
friends that that you may have that you
family that you can involve in in
turning a decent machine translation
into a very good very good site and
still maintain the benefits of the lower
price and most importantly the speed of
automatic translation by allowing you to
have an always current always up-to-date
site where a portion is is raw
translated what hasn't been edited yet
and you can involve your community after
it has been been published that's a very
successful morale for instance for for
knowledgebase site activities we are the
times of the of the essence and you want
to give your community a way to interact
with it for instance the support agents
and turn a turn a maybe not not
perfectly fluent automatic translation
into something that is easily
understandable all right but today we're
not going to go in
in depth on that on that either our
mentioning this because you always get
better results with a customized
translation translation engine if the
translation system is they're familiar
with your product names with your
product features with the things that
these products are doing then you will
get a better automatic translation and
then using a generic system so and I
want to go here into a little bit
background on the hub itself as I
mentioned - of translator is a
statistical empty system a benefit of
statistical empty system is that they
automatically learn from previously
translated documents and in fact also
can learn from a monolingual documents
in the in the target language as you see
here picture of the rosetta stone which
is the earliest known example of a
multilingual document here in three
languages and that's the basis of
statistical machine translation so the
beauty of it is that you can add data
fairly dynamically it isn't helpful or
maybe detrimental and you simply to
retrain the system and then you will get
a new machine translation engine without
needing a linguist or a MT expert to to
fine-tune the system it really lowers
the barrier to entry in give it gives
machine translation providers like
ourselves the ability to provide a
fairly large language language coverage
at scale so what you do is you you
collect collect training data so we do
that for the generics
them and you do that already as part of
your regular translation activity you
provided to the statistical a training
system to build what's called a model
model is simply an algorithm that gives
you a statistical answer meaning and a
set of answers with probabilities and
then you deploy it as part of a as part
of a runtime system we think we do in
doing it particularly well by running it
so how does it work with with your data
so let's start on the right side here's
the hub you provide bilingual documents
for instance aur translation memory or
any collection of previously translated
documents and other formats say office
documents PDFs plain text files that are
document aligned so it's the same
document in two languages you also
provide or can provide that's optional
provide a target language material that
are representative of the domain or the
product that you are the set of products
that you that you want to translate you
can add as much as much as you want as
no there's no upper limit to it you get
a set of options to choose from you can
choose to train with Microsoft models or
without without means with the system
without even thesis Muses only your own
data in in almost all cases you get
better results if you use a Microsoft
models you can choose any subset of the
data that you have that you are provided
you can build multiple systems for
instance if you say have a if your if
your business is active in multiple
domains or if you have a language
service providers to satisfy multiple
customers you can segregate these
customers by assigning different names
and category values to those you can
build your community of collaborators
say your so your close
workers or maybe your customer or your
language service provider to work
collaboratively with you on the on day
system and you can assign certain rights
to them you can supply dictionaries you
will continuously be able to monitor the
quality and you can use the system to
either interactively create training
data or import data from the widget or
the collaborative translation framework
these these the interactively create
training data is not used much by our
enterprise customers but it's you it's
used a lot by language communities
communities who who use our system to
build support for their language that is
not covered by a Microsoft translator
yet so here on the on the consumption
side well you you you make all these
selections and I'll show you the UI to
do that it's it's much easier than it
sounds right here you train and you
train the system you will get results
and you can interactively improve your
system and then you hit deploy which
causes your your training to be deployed
in a Microsoft data center where where
it then becomes available as part of the
Microsoft translator API and you get a
key that allows you to access your own
your own system then add at the at the
runtime the the system will also the
training will ever sign a weight to your
data versus versus Microsoft's generic
morals and the runtime system combines
these dynamically and give you the best
so what are the steps you need to go
through you set up your project invite
your people you conduct trainings and we
train as
Caesaria ting and modifying your
training data then you share it with
your you others optionally share with
your community and and you you test it
out and then so this is the simple
project setup here you have uploaded a
number of documents and the system will
tell you the size of it and you can add
more documents or you can import your
community translation
you also have tabs which I'm not going
to explain more in detail tools to
submit your tuning set and your testing
so the tuning set is used for the system
to optimize itself the testing set is
used to for you to generate a score and
there's a dictionary table where you can
force certain phrases to be translated a
certain way that's a fairly dangerous
feature but but also very useful if used
correctly here use you can immediately
after you have done a training can
immediately see the results compare the
automatic translation to your reference
translation you can also interactively
try out what the system did and here you
get a category code which you can
immediately use in the Microsoft
translator API to refer to your train
system here this is an example of a
series of of trainings that you went
through
we used the fairly standard blues going
to to assign a Equality so you can
choose the best system here and and
choose to deploy it
that means it's part of the part of the
translator API the assumption here is
that you go through a series of of
trainings in order to get the best the
best results for your test set
this is just a general overview of all
the systems that that that you have
built and each of them have may have a
series of trainings associated with it
Microsoft Word is one system that allows
you to use a customized customized MT
system you use the the Microsoft
translator app as part of office 2013
here on the right side you see that the
configuration you simply copy the code
that you got here into this Microsoft
Word utility and then you can access
your system and this is how you do it
you simply make a selection in your text
you don't have to choose the target
language you may if we make a mistake
you choose Europe
so you don't have to choose the source
language but it's the target language
and then you see here the translation
right there works works very nicely does
whatever collection it whatever
selection you make is being translated
and then you can immediately insert the
translation translation here there are a
lot of other tools that allow you to
access a customized empty system and
I've listed here the the the translation
memory tools that allow you access of
translator the ones that are labeled
gold or silver support customized MT
system the bronze ones only only allow
you to access they the generic system at
this point so what you have a you have a
wide selection you know of TM tools
alright in order to use the hub you
simply visit hopped-up - our translator
comm or you can also send send me a mail
you click request an invitation and then
you will get an invitation there is no
no cost and no obligation to it only
once you decide to use it at a scale of
more than 2 million characters per month
you have to pay us and he is simply the
set of set of contact points and I am
passing it on to Marcus now